[موسيقى
] لقد أخذت استراحة من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بسبب صحتي العقلية في مقطع فيديو نُشر
على الإنستغرام ، قال الممثل توم هولاند إن
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي أضرت
بحالته العقلية ، لذا فقد تراجع عن
هولندا ولديه أكثر من 67 مليون
متابع على Instagram وأكثر من
سبعة ملايين على تويتر ولكن لم
ينشروا هذا كثيرًا على
البشر حديثًا هم كائنات اجتماعية
بطبيعتها ، ولكن
تمامًا مثل كل الأشياء ، هناك الكثير
من الأشياء الجيدة التي تقضيها الكثير من الوقت
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يمكن أن تقضي على
قدرتك على عيش الحياة  بدلاً من ذلك ، أنت فقط
تحصل على تعليق مستمر على ذلك ، تقول
أريانا غالاغر ، المدير المساعد
لمركز أوهايو ستيت ستار للتعافي من الصدمات ،
فقط أن تكون قادرًا على
القول إنني أعاني
وأكون قادرًا على اكتشاف أنك لست
وحدك في هذا
الأمر.  يقول جالاغر القوي إن وجود بعض
الأشخاص على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ليس
فكرة جيدة بشكل عام ، فهي لا تجلب
لهم الاتصال أو الفرح الذي
يبحثون عنه للآخرين الذين يتراجعون
ويعيدون الانخراط في  قد تعمل الطريقة المتعمدة بشكل
أفضل ، فهي تأمل أن يتبع الآخرون
خطوات هولندا ولكل شخص هناك ، شكرًا لحبك ودعمك ، أحبك جميعًا وسأتحدث إليك قريبًا للحصول على دقيقة صحية ، أنا ماندي غايثر
[موسيقى]